[Music]
on this saturday night
the long weekend and the long pandemic
more covet cases more shutdown measures
it feels
heavier and harder this time around one
province leads
with a worrisome spike the motive behind
the attack on the u.s capitol
hot housing market will the federal
government intervene
to cool it down plus the great outdoors
and the greater demand for boats and rvs
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us canada has now surpassed
one million cases of coven 19. and there
are more signs this pandemic is getting
worse
tonight alberta's chief medical officer
says the province is investigating a
significant outbreak
involving the highly transmissible p1
variant which first originated in brazil
it's linked to a returning traveler but
no other details are available
today alberta bc and quebec are all
reporting more than a thousand new
infections
and in ontario there were more than
three 000 new coven 19 cases
for the second day in a row the hard hit
provinces are taking more measures
to curb the rapid spread of the virus
but new variants are competing with
pandemic fatigue abigail beeman has our
top story tonight
we can't because of coven there are a
lot of
cants this easter the casey family lives
in gatineau quebec one of three regions
in a new lockdown with
schools and non-essential businesses
closed a little lonely it's kind of
you know it'd be nice to be around
family and stuff i got my folks doing a
drive
by uh easter easter hunt
from montreal but then you know they
have to go home
montreal isn't part of the shutdown
though many are calling for it to be
with the rise of the variants which are
more infectious and seem to be causing
more severe disease we have to realize
that we are not out of the woods yet
the entire province of ontario is now
under a new
28-day shutdown with more than 3 000 new
cases reported each day friday and
saturday
i'm really scared based on the numbers
we're seeing
and what we're seeing in the hospital so
i saw over three weeks ago
what i felt was the start of wave three
and i knew we were going to be in
trouble
some like this emergency room doctor
want stricter measures like closing
schools in hot spots
the thing i'm most fearful for is that i
will be responsible
for impacting one of the 165 kids that i
see every single day because i
move room to room while the province
faces pushback for not
prioritizing teacher and other essential
worker vaccinations fast enough
it feels heavier and harder this time
around
with a third wave comes a new kind of
pandemic fatigue
more people are resistant to
restrictions with some businesses
defying orders to close
this latest one they've gone too far
that earned this restaurant owner a
padlock
but he was back open for permitted
takeout and patio dining
saturday it's great that bc
is recognizing that we are in the throes
of
we're at the start of the third wave and
a circuit breaker is exactly what's
needed
saskatchewan extended its measures to
cover the long weekend until at least
april 12th
with different rules all over the
country one thing everyone agrees on
tonight i might like set my
ipad on a recording so i
maybe could catch the easter bunny
lockdown
shut down or restricted none of it
applies
to the easter bunny abigail beeman
global news
ottawa vaccines have provided some hope
we will
finally be able to get ahead of this
pandemic but the speed of the rollout is
no match for the highly transmissible
variants
now fueling this third wave a supply
ramp up is expected in the coming weeks
and as eric sorensen reports that could
make a big difference in the race
between vaccines and variants
finally signs of success in canada's
vaccination program
close to three quarters of canadians
over the age of 80 have now received at
least one dose
and provinces are now reaching out to
younger age groups it comes after a
tense few weeks when vaccine shipments
were temporarily cut by pfizer and
moderna as recently as this week
ontario's premier was getting testy with
ottawa we still
don't have the steady and reliable
supply of mass vaccines
that we need from the federal government
it has been a bumpy road for a country
suffering covid fatigue
several nations including the uk and the
u.s manufactured large numbers of doses
and got a head start on much of the
world canada among many was desperate to
catch up
international vaccine distribution began
three months ago
at the end of january canada was
virtually even with comparable countries
having vaccinated around two percent of
the population but after deliveries to
canada were cut
this country fell well behind many
others deliveries though have since
picked up
and by the end of march canada pulled
ahead of france italy and germany
with over 13 percent of canadians having
received at least one dose
indeed ottawa now says 9.5 million doses
will have been distributed across canada
by this weekend
and 40 million by the end of june
meaning provinces will now have to be
ready for a surge of vaccines
we have completed a series of exercises
dry runs and rehearsals with more than
150 stakeholders
and federal provincial and territorial
partners from across the country
to prepare for an unprecedented
distribution of vaccines
across the nation but another
unprecedented surge is also taking place
at hospitals like this one covet
variants are putting more and younger
canadians into icu beds
vaccinations will not happen soon enough
to fully blunt a third wave of cases
says one icu doctor young individuals
are getting very sick
coming into the hospital and it's
steadily climbing and
that population is not going to get
vaccinated in the coming weeks to months
so unless particular populations are
targeted
to address this i'm worried that this is
going to continue to rise
case numbers will rise but as vaccines
are administered in large numbers
particular populations can be targeted
such as those in congregate settings
food processing plans
jails homeless shelters and these are
the areas i think that the highest risk
once we start to vaccinate that sector
of the population you're going to see
that the
pandemic will really decelerate
especially going into the warmer months
covid variants are expected to hold the
upper hand for some weeks
but vaccines are coming and the
timetable is moving up
for more and more canadians to get their
shots eric sorensen
global news toronto the vaccination
campaign may be ramping up in this
country but canada still has a long way
to go
israel is vaccinating its population
faster than any other country
according to our world in data it has
administered more than 116 doses for
every 100 people
canada is way down the global list
ranked lower than 40th in the world
so far 15 doses have been given for
every 100 people here
but some developing countries have yet
to administer a single dose
the world health organization has warned
the world is on the brink of a
catastrophic
moral failure in italy millions of
people are now under a nationwide
lockdown
police in rome set up roadblocks to
ensure people are following the strict
new rules
italians are only allowed out for
essential reasons including exercise
almost all shops are closed and
restaurants are open for takeout only
churches are open for easter but
worshipers are being told to attend
services in their own regions
the three-day lockdown is aimed at
fighting a new wave of coven-19
infections
italy is seeing about 20 000 new cases
a day in france a stadium has been
temporarily turned into a mass
vaccination center
hundreds of people are lining up to get
the shot the french government hopes to
vaccinate tens of thousands of people
over the next three days
tomorrow france will enter its third
national lockdown
the country is seeing a rise in cases
that end up in the icu
hospitals brought in extra staff this
weekend to deal with the growing number
of patients
investigators are still trying to
determine the motive behind yesterday's
deadly attack in washington d.c
a car rammed into a security barrier
killing a police officer
and seriously injuring another the
attack comes just months after the
deadly insurrection on the u.s capitol
and as jennifer johnson explains it's
once again raising security questions
another tragedy for u.s capitol police
on what should be a holiday weekend of
celebration
investigators are now trying to
determine what led 25-year-old
noah green to drive his car into two
policemen
killing officer william evans and
injuring a second officer
green litter crashed into a barrier
emerged holding a knife
and was shot and killed we do not have
the suspect on file
with u.s capitol police so there's no
indication
at this time that there is any nexus to
any member of congress
police do not believe green had ties to
any terrorist organization either
that he acted alone and according to his
facebook page was unemployed and having
a tough time
this attack came less than three months
after january's insurrection at the
capitol
that left officer brian sicknick dead
two other officers later took their own
lives
a committee is now reviewing how to
better fortify the building and protect
lawmakers
who were not in session during this
latest incident they can't fall into the
other
political arguments that we're having
this is about the security of the
nation's capital
that's the temple of democracy an outer
perimeter
fence erected after the january riot was
recently taken down
a permanent fence is being debated which
will keep tourists and
residents much further away than ever
before from the so-called
people's house but many stunned by
yesterday's attack
are expecting it i'm afraid things are
just not going to open up again now
i'm no security expert but i would say
leave things as they are now there's
going to be a perimeter somewhere
officer evans an 18-year veteran with
the force was a father of two
friends say it was his dream to become a
capital police officer
he was so proud to be you know on that
force and to
serve and protect our lawmakers and our
country
in that way flags again have been
ordered to fly at half-mast in the
nation's capital
as this police force prepares to bury
another officer
jennifer johnson global news washington
there has been an alarming increase of
anti-asian hate
in canada major cities are reporting
crimes targeting people of asian descent
have increased as much as 700 percent
compared to the previous year
small business and international trade
minister mary ing spoke about the
troubling trend
with our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson for this weekend's edition
of the west block mercedes
robin a recent report by the chinese
canadian national council's toronto
chapter
found that there were 1150 incidents of
anti-asian racism in canada during the
pandemic
the report said many incidents involve
people physically attacking
spitting at or coughing on asian
canadians
i asked international trade minister
mary ing about this
disturbing trend i think one of the most
heartbreaking things
was just uh about a week ago when a very
good friend of mine
in vancouver sent me a text that his 70
year old grandma
his seven-year-old mother sent to him
she was worried about going out for a
walk and wanted to know where she might
be able to buy pepper spray
this is canada how is that happening
today
ing said she's been working with
community leaders and law enforcement
to reduce the rise in racist incidents
she says it can start
even in your own front yard i hope that
if you're walking down a street and you
see
you see anti-asian racism taking place
that you
stand up i think that canadians
i think canadians want to do the right
thing we've always proven time after
time that we do
we're going to need our allies we need
to stand up against racism
period we'll stop i also asked mary ing
about one of her key
portfolios small business with new
lockdowns being
announced what measures is she
considering to help those small
businesses
in the federal budget tune in sunday
morning to find out
robin mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes
coming up calls for speculation tax to
cool down the housing market
this month the federal government will
unveil its first budget
in more than two years and there's
growing pressure on ottawa to address
the overheating
housing market this week the bank of
canada's governor said he's seen
worrying signs canadians are taking on
more debt
to chase rising prices michael couture
looks at some of the options the trudeau
government may be considering
to cool the market they are the literal
signs of the times in canada's red hot
housing market
according to the canadian real estate
association last year
the average home price in this country
was over 570 thousand dollars
crea expects the national average home
price to climb
this year to just over 665 thousand
dollars
we're at this this crossroads where we
have very very inflated housing markets
and
real estate broker john pasalis believes
it's time for the federal government to
step
in and help cool down the market across
the country
especially when it comes to real estate
speculation
i think any policies that the government
puts in place should should really
be making it harder for investors to
capitalize on the housing market
not necessarily putting in policies that
make it harder for
first-time buyers to get into the market
a nationwide speculation tax is just one
of the tools at the federal government's
disposal
to discourage house flipping which
drives up prices
another thing driving the market is a
growing number of canadians
were worried they could be left out of
the market boom
but there are other things ottawa could
do to help make housing more affordable
as the pandemic
has people looking for more living space
another idea
is to broadly increase capital gains on
the sale of a home
but the minister in charge of housing
says that's not
on the table we are not considering
introducing
tax attacks on on on
on residences and equity there is
mounting pressure on the bank of canada
and other authorities to address the
overheating housing market
in places like toronto and lower
mainland bc
but it's now at the point where the
canada mortgage and housing corporation
is warning
markets like ottawa hamilton halifax and
moncton
are considered overvalued in a statement
a spokesperson for the finance minister
christian freeland said we continue to
monitor
the health and stability of the housing
market we cannot however comment
on what may or may not be under
consideration for the upcoming
2021 budget and some feel the government
may not have to intervene mortgage rates
bottomed really
in january so as some of those
you know pre-approvals start to expire i
do think some of the steam
is going to come out of this market the
government may not be
able to wait it out the federal budget
is set to be tabled
in less than three weeks michael couture
global news ottawa
still ahead mourning the victims of
taiwan's train disaster and tracking
down a suspect in the deadly crash
you're watching global national
[Music]
heartbroken families gathered to mourn
the victims of a deadly train disaster
in taiwan
at least 51 people died friday when a
high-speed passenger train
derailed as it passed through a tunnel
an unoccupied truck
struck the train after rolling down a
bank from a construction site
above the tracks the manager of the
construction site was released on bond
today
investigators believe he may have
forgotten to properly set the vehicle's
handbrake once again protesters in
myanmar
are holding their ground in cities
across the country in the face of the
military's
unrelenting crackdown on demonstrations
security forces opened fire on
demonstrators in the central part of the
country
the number of people killed since the
february first coup has topped
550. nearly 50 of them were children
the military's ongoing internet
blackouts have not deterred crowds from
taking to the streets to demand the
return of the country's
democratically elected government this
march in the southern district included
teachers
engineers and members of the lgbtq
community
the backlog of ships waiting to get
through the suez canal is finally
cleared
85 vessels transited the canal today
most of them had been idling at either
end since the ever given a 400 meter
long container ship
ran aground march 23rd in high winds
it took six days to free it and get
traffic moving again
the fallout from the ordeal isn't over
egypt may seek up to a billion dollars
u.s in compensation
a government official says the ever
given will remain anchored in an
artificial lake
until its owners pay egypt's capital was
lit up in a spectacle
fit for the pharaohs
22 royal mummies were paraded through
the streets of cairo
in specially designed capsules filled
with nitrogen to protect them
the remains of the ancient rulers 18
kings and four queens
were transported from the egyptian
museum to their new home
at the national museum of egyptian
civilization
it's hoped the pharaoh's golden parade
as it was called
will renew interest in ancient egyptian
civilization
and give the country's struggling
tourism industry a boost
up next the booming sales for the
outdoors as canadians prep for another
coveted summer
a couple in south korea got in big
trouble after accidentally vandalizing
graffiti artwork by american artist
john one the piece is worth over six
hundred thousand dollars
the pair thought audience participation
was allowed after seeing
pots of paint and brushes in front of
the piece there were no charges but a
small fence and do not touch signs
now guard the work most businesses were
hit hard during the pandemic's early
days
but when summer came one industry
started thriving
outdoor recreation for example from june
to september 2020
swimming pool sales saw a 51 increase
the bicycle boom up 21 and recreational
boat sales were up 58
from the year before it looks like
another summer of cova discontent
and deshawn o'shea reports the demand
for recreational items
is skyrocketing once again it's only
spring but with a second coveted summer
ahead
canadians are ready to shell out i'm
just spending
my money on some fishing gear lockdowns
travel bans and other restrictions are
keeping people closer to home
again everybody wants to get outdoors or
renovate their house
viewers tell us they can't find outdoor
furniture new bicycles are back ordered
and out of stock everywhere
same with all terrain vehicles fitness
equipment is in short supply
and pricey the list goes on
but big ticket items present some of the
biggest challenges
take boats for example it's possible
you'll find something you want new
right now 60 days from now
i'm going to say it's going to go the
other way sean 90 of that opportunity be
gone
back on land it's even more challenging
in the rv industry
proven has certainly accelerated the
appeal of our being across all age
groups
um you know rentals are up 650 percent
and manufacturers have been unable to
keep up with
the demand and growth this lot in
burlington 90 percent of the units have
been sold
we'd recommend you put your name on one
and it'll come in in the next four
to eight months and they're disappointed
smaller units like this one are among
the hottest sellers
dinette double door refrigerator demand
is high but supply chain problems
because of covet
have slowed down deliveries the texas
state of emergency last month
was unbelievable it affected you think
of
oil business from texas it affects
plastics glue
so many pieces that are used on trailers
the resale market for rvs and boats is
booming too
but a caution buyer beware make sure you
understand what you're buying buy from a
reputable firm consumers are caught up
in a mood to buy paying a lot more than
usual for a chance to spend time
outdoors sean o'shea global news
hamilton
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm robin gill we leave you
tonight with a new take on easter
[Music]
in new brunswick the easter bunny is
making an appearance but this rabbit
knows how
important it is to stick to pandemic
protocols there was a drive-through
option to get the easter eggs
to the kids thanks for watching have a
great night